s
consommateurs espèrent et c'est
ce qu'on a pu constater en sont
donc en se rendant sur letetete.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On n'a pas vu d'enseignes
proche encore. Puis avant ça,
il y d d d des grosses enseignes
partout, puis... Il y a rien!
- Pas de fièvre électorale
dans le quartier de
Denis Desaulniers.
- Nos votes valent pas
grand-chose.iriririre)
- Ici, la campagne ne soulève
visiblement pas les passions.
Et Denis ne sait pas encore
pour qui voter.
DENIS DESAULNIERS, travailleur
dans l'industrie automobile
- C'est une décision
qu'il faut que je prenne.
Je sais pas encore.
- D'habitude, Denis vote
pour les néo-démocrates
ou les libéraussss
cette fois-ci, il pourrait
choisir les conservateurs.
- M. Ford, il essaie bien fort
de rentrer à Windsor.
- Le pe e e e famille travaille
dans le secteur automobile
depuis 28 ans, et voit
d'un bon oeil les promesses de
Doug Ford pour son industrie.
- On a eu beaucoup de temps
qu'on restait à la maison,
on pouvait même pas travailler
parce qu'il y avai
d'ouvrage!
Maintenant, on a un futur.
Ça vient des conservateurs,
qui ont aidé beaucoup.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il est 15 h à l'usine Chrysler
de Windsor. C'est la fin
d'un quart de travail,
et les ouvriers retournent
à la maison. Ici aussi,
les indécis sont nombreux.
D'autres, comme Mike, ont déjà
pris leur décision.
Normalement fidèle au NPD,
il votera bleu cette fois-ci.
♪ ♪ ♪
Située à quelques kilomètres de
Détroit, Windsor est la capitale
canadienne de l'auto.
La région est ouvri
Les syndicats y sont nombreux.
Et la gauche traditionnelle,
bien établie.
Pendant longtemps, la région
a été un fiecrcrcrcrcrcrate.
Mais cette année, le NPD
pourrait y perdre des plumes,
et les conservateurs y faire
quelques prises.
Do c c c c c cache pas
ses ambitions dans la région :
depuis des mois, le premier
ministre sortant courtiseememem.
En mars, le gouver
a frappé fort en concluant
un accord pour construire
une usine de batteries
de voitures.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Un investissement de 5 milliards
de dollars, qui devrait créer
2500 emplois.
Dave Cassidy est le président du
plus grand syndicat de Windsor.
Parmi ses membres, beaucoup de
travailleurs de l'auto, dont
certains qui ont toujours
voté à droite.
"35 % de nos membres votent
conservateur", dit
Un chiffre qui risque
d'augmenter avec la popularité
de Doug Ford.
Mais au-delà du phénomène Ford,
Dave constplplplplplplplplus
fondamental dans le mouvement
ouvrier. La loyauté à un parti
n'est plus ce qu'elle était,
et les travailleurs de l'auto
sont loin de constituer
un électorat homogène.
♪ ♪ ♪
Sur le terrain, Andrew Dowie
constate aussi ce changement
de mentalité.
Depuis des semaines, le ca
conservateur dans Windsor-
Tecumseh cogne aux portes
sans arrêt.
Ça va bien?
- Ça va très bi
- Nous le retrouvons sur
la rue Denby, dans un quartier
de l'est de la ville.
Conseiller municipal depuis
2014, Andrew mil
Parti progressiste-conservateur
depuis des années.
(Une femme lui parle
en anglais.)
C'est sa première élection
provinciale en tant que
candidat. Et l'ingénieur de
formation fait des pieds et des
mains pour charmer les indécis.
- Je crois que je peux trouver
assez de votes pour gagner.
- De retour dans son bureau
de campagne, Andrew se dit
convaincu d'avoir des chances
de l'emporter.
- J'ai jamais eu de réactionssi.
- Andrew estime qu'il a besoin
d'aller chercher 3000 voix
de plus qu'en 2018 pour battre
le NPD.
"Un résultat atteignable,
dit-il, maintenant que
les néo-démocrates n'ont plus
le monopole sur le vote
des cols bleus."
ANDREW DOWIE, candidat du PCC
dans Windsor-Tecumseh
NPNPNPNPNPNPNPNPNPNPD a changé,
ils ne représentent plus
les intérêts des travailleurs.
- Dans le bureau de campagne
de Gemma Grey-Hall, on met d d r
conserver ce château fort.
- C'est plus difficile qu'en
2018?
- Ici, absolument.
- Le responsable de campagne
s'attend à une course serrée.
popopopopopopopopopoponsable de
campagne néo-démocrate
- C'est pas normal pour
un conservateur d'avoir
une bonne chance pour être élu.t
convaincu que son parti
pourra compter sur le vote
d'une majorité de travailleurs.
- M. Fnenenenenenenenenenener
comme un champion pour
les ouvriers, c'est pas
la vérité.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans la circonscription
voisine d'Essex, le NPD faitàààe
concurrence.
Ron LeClair, un ancien policiere
provinciale, se bat pour que
la circonscription reste orange.
"Je marche à peu près 16 km
par jour", lance Ron.s's's's's',
La course s'annonce serrée,
mais le candidat est confiant.
- Ce qui est important,
c'est le style de leadership.
- Cette politologue s'attend
à ce que le NPD perde au moins
un siège dans la région
de Windsor. Pour Emmanuelle
Richer, ces luttes serrées
révèlent la fragmentation
de la coalition néo-démocr
Et le clivage urbain-rural
de plus en plus marqué.
EMMANUELLE RICHEZ, prof. science
politique, Université de Windsor
- Andrea Horwath n'a
à mobiliser à la fois le vote
des travailleurs et le vote
des activistes de gauche qui
habitent dans les centres-villes
de la provin
- C'est beaucoup d'emplois, ça,
dans Windsor-Essex.
- Bien qu'indécis,nenenenenenene
pas de parler politique avec
ses voisins.
- Je pense qu'il a fait
de son mieux.
- Marc Marentette, un autre
travailleur de l'auto, a pris
sa décision. Dans son comté,
il votera pour un parti marginal
de droite, mais
quand même que les conservateurs
formeront le gouvernement.
MARC MARENTETTE, travailleur
dans l'industrie automobile
- Je
une majorité.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un indécis et un électeur
de droite conv
À eux deux, Denis et Marc
prouvent que l'électorat
ouvrier n'est plus acquis
à un seul parti.
Face à
changeant, les candidats devront
ajuster leur message.
Répondre aux attentes
des cols bleus, et esp
que la récolte sera bonne.